الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قال ان بلاده
وجهت رساله خاصه الى ايران بخصوص الضربات
التي نفذت على مواقع خاضعه لسيطره
الحوثيين في اليمن وفي تصريح للصحفيين
قبيل مغادرته البيت الابيض متوجها الى
منتجع كم ديفيد الرئاسي اضاف بايدن ان
بلاده مستعده بشكل جيد للتعامل مع الوضع
في
المنطقه ينضم الى من طهران مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد القادر فايز عبد القادر كيف
تلقت ايران هذه
الرساله حقيقه من غير المعلوم هل يتحدث
الرئيس بايدن عن رساله جديده
لايران قبل يوم او يومين مثلا من ضرب او
توجيه الضربات الى اليمن وبان ايران ردت
على هذه الرساله ام انه يتحدث عن الرساله
سابقه التي كانت ايران قد كشفت عنها قبل
ما يقارب اكثر من عره ايام على لسان
السفير الايراني في سوريا وكذلك بعض
المصادر الخاصه هنا هنا في طهران التي
قالت بان امريكا ارسلت رساله ل ايران عبر
طرف خليجي وبات معروفا بانه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبانها طلبت من ايران
مجموعه من الطلبات من بين هذه الطلبات كان
هناك بندا اصيلا وواسعا يتعلق بالبحر
الاحمر وبحوث في اليمن وامن البلا الملاحه
وبان تقوم ايران بشيء ما يومها قالت ايران
بان امريكا عرضت في هذا الموضوع ما اسمته
بالتسويه الكبرى وبان الرد الايراني كان
بانه يجب على الامريكيين ان يتواصلوا مع
انصار الله في اليمن فهذه قضايا يقررها
انصار الله في اليمن وا المستقبل السياسي
لهؤلاء في اليمن ومصير اليمن بيد هؤلاء
بشكل او باخر ايه اذا ما كنا نتحدث عن هذه
الرساله فهذه باتت معروفه التفاصيل وبات
الرد الايراني معروف ولكن اذا ما نحن
نتحدث الان عن رساله جديده قبل ايام قليله
من توجيه الضربات الامريكيه البريطانيه
المشتركه لانصار الله فايران حتى الان لم
تتحدث عن اي شيء ولم تعلق على اي شيء لذلك
حقيقه معرفه الكلام الامريكي
و دقه ما يتحدث عنه الرئيس الامريكي حقيقه
من حيث التوقيت هو مهم جدا ولكن بكافه
الاحوال فدا يمكن ان نقول بان الرسائل
الامريكيه السابقه وهي باتت ربما اكثر من
ست رسائل وصلت هنا الى طهران منذ السابع
من اكتوبر من العام الماضي حتى الان تلقت
ربما الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ردا يمكن
ان يوصف بانه سلبيا نوعا ما من قبل ايران
لماذا لان ايران تعتقد بان امريكا في
سياساتها الشرق اوسطيه هي جزء من المشكله
وليست جزءا من الحل وتقول بان الضربات
الاخيره التي وجهت من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا لليمن ستفتح
صيغه ما من المواجهه بين انصار الله وال
القوات الامريكيه الموجوده في المنطقه
وبان ذلك سيعقد بشكل او باخر الامن
الاقليمي لذلك يمكن ان نقول بان ايران وهي
حليف نوعا ما لانصار الله تدرك تماما
اهميه ما يجري في البحر الاحمر وباب
المندب لانه جزء اصيل من الامن القومي
الايراني ولكن لا احد يتوقع حقيقه فدا ان
تقوم ايران بضغط مباشر ربما على انصار
الله في اليمن حتى لو كانت تستطيع ذلك ان
تفعل ذلك فقط لان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تريد ذلك هناك امن اقليمي
متشابك بالنسبه لايران وايران ترى اليمن
كما قال وزير الخارجيه يوم امس وكذلك
اليوم هناك تصريحات ترى اليمن بانه جزء
اصيل من منظومه الامن الاقليمي وبان
استهداف اليمن بضربات عسكريه سيعرض هذا
الامن الاقليمي لخطر في جوانب منه وتنهي
كل هذه السرديه ربما بان الاساس في كل ما
يجري هو ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تمتنع عن الضغط على اسرائيل لوقف الحرب في
غزه بينما تهاجم وتفتح حروب اخرى في
المنطقه فقط لانها تريد ان تدعم اسرائيل
وهذا الكلام بطبيعه الحال هو للمنظومه
السياسيه والعسكريه هنا في شكرا لك من
طهران مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد القادر فايز